hello there hi Chris Traeger this is Ben
I really like your shoes I'd like to
talk about where you think there's waste
within your department
you're a jerk I'm sorry sorry these are
real people in a real town working in a
real building with real feelings
this building has feelings maybe there's
a lot of history in this one maybe it
does how can you be so blasé but because
I didn't cause these problems miss Knope
your government did okay listen
a professional I hello Ben look I kind
of feel like we got off on the wrong
foot so I just wanted to stop by yeah
well save your breath okay just get out
of here because this is a party with my
friends and you're trying to fire all my
friends close I just talked to everybody
in this bar and nobody wants you here
okay then I'll just see you tomorrow
sorry to bother you get out of here
mostly I was so professional I'd like to
apologize for yesterday don't worry
about it
know what I did was out of line twice
and I was worked up because obviously
you represent a threat to my department
we're City Council and your mayor are
the threats to your department we didn't
do anything to get you into this
situation okay okay look Ben I don't
appreciate your callous attitude okay
yeah really good
you may hold my fate in your hands like
a small bird but I still think you're an
ass you want to get a beer
like 10:30 in the morning yeah you seem
like you could use a beer
it's good a beer I'm sorry that I yelled
at you all three times but I don't think
you know anything about my department
have you ever been part of a government
body before I have yeah
a small town called Partridge Minnesota
why is this other manner you're Benji
Wyatt
I am god I was so jealous of you you
shouldn't have been I mean it ended up
kind of ruining my life you know I'm
balancing budgets so I can show people
I'm responsible so I can run for office
again someday and not be laughed at
now I mean you want to run for office
someday right yeah
how'd you know well you have to be able
to make decisions like this Leslie you
have to be harsh you know it's gonna
elect you to do anything if you don't
show that you're a responsible grown-up
yeah
we'll sit down and tell me exactly
what's happened well every year we kick
off the summer with a children's concert
series and this year the concert has
been canceled due to the shutdown it's
terrible and we need to fix it oh all
right
great I'm very glad that you agree with
me even actually worked really hard and
my argument is there any way I can still
kind of yeah I'd love to hear oh good
thank you you're wrong are you crazy
can you put a price tag on a child smile
Leslie Knope what a surprise
the government has been shut down for
two days and one city employee has tried
to schedule 14 meetings with me
can you guess who the concert is
canceled everybody here's the thing
though Ben it's not canceled we're
putting it on okay because the stage is
already built everything was donated for
free by local vendors everyone here
believes that what we're doing is
essential Freddy spaghetti will sing
actually Leslie I just found out Freddy
spaghetti ain't coming Freddy spaghetti
may not sing but something much cooler
is going to happen I think and
if you're happy being you know it clap
your hands if you're happy and you know
it
[Music]
[Applause]
all I know is this guy showed up made me
a much better offer all about the money
baby she could see Tina why did you do
this well I'm not a monster I want the
kids to have their concert I mean Ben is
a soft spot is that what you guys call
me Ben no no this is really great
today but there's gonna be a lot of pain
ahead Leslie we have to cut 32% oh
please just stop it okay just for one
moment enjoy the fact that you provided
a service for people not a cut a service
and they loved it
biggest service was getting you to stop
singing I'm getting better all right
you're burning up you're burning up what
the time is now the place is Pawnee
let's make history that was amazing
that was a flu ridden Michael Jordan at
the 97 NBA Finals that was Kirk Gibson
hobbling up to the plate and hitting a
homer off of Dennis Eckersley that was
that was Leslie Knope oh hey I got you
some waffles here courtesy of JJ's diner
and chicken soup courtesy of me take a
waffle thank you
so how did the rest of the meeting go um
well you said you needed 80 total
businesses to participate yeah we have
110 and Counting so uh
nice work Leslie please 4200
left the chicken soup there just in case
it's a old family recipe it's not a big
deal but thank you for that okay
hey he's back I'm sorry I left honestly
felt like I was cursed or something nice
town and now this his town was a
disaster and it seems like it was
probably your fault when I can tell you
mismanaged the hell out of it
Wow why even say that right the point is
this project this is as much yours as it
is mine it's ours and it's gonna be
really great and I'm glad you're here
thank you I really think you should just
do whatever makes you happy
that's what April and I did we are in
love all the good ones are taken hi bro
[Music]
hey you should stay don't go back to
Indianapolis
we should stay here okay yeah yes
it's a great city here you know and
there are great people
and you've made a lot of friends yeah
what are you gonna do go back to your
old job and hack up people's budgets
stay here help us build something I
already accepted the job I'm staying
here
that's good yeah I think so I'm
[Music]
Oren's behind me isn't yeah yep okay
okay so just keep your eyes on her
don't panic cuz you can smell fear we're
already talking part hi how are you good
how are you how's the front
I just wanted to make sure that there
were no hard feelings after I forced you
to break up a top Oh
we were no no hard feelings cuz just
real Bugaboo of mine and it applies to
everyone just the other day Ben told me
that he might want to socialize with
somebody from the government nice and
I'm sorry possible really did he say who
no and I didn't ask
cuz it's relevant he oversees every
department hey what's up hey well I
think I'm allergic to chutney
also what's chutney no clue yeah hey I
never got to tell you the rest of my
ideas who want to go somewhere who
talked about them yeah I'd love to let
me get some actual food and then do you
know that wildflower mural up on the
second floor mm-hmm yeah I'm gonna meet
there yeah okay sounds good
- is she is this powerful goddess and
I've been thinking a lot about powerful
women and subconsciously I painted you
yeah you know she wasn't really my type
she's a tall brunette you always like
topper nets well not exclusively
historically yes exclusively you said
you didn't like her so it's over okay
well I'm gonna keep trying because you
are incredible thank you and you deserve
someone amazing and smart and beautiful
thank you a real goddess exactly hmm
Leslie its Leslie Knope from the parks
department speaking to you through ad
Perkins friend a beautiful nurse thank
you
do not do anything with Ben be
responsible no matter how cute his mouth
is your job is on the line
shut up Ann you wrote that no you then
Leslie Leslie you don't know what you're
talking about
I care about him very much and I've had
two and a half glasses of red wine and
what that means is I'm gonna go make out
with him right now and it's gonna be
awesome yeah yeah no you're supposed to
talk me out of this no don't stop shut
up Ann I'm doing it anyway
yay lastly
you